so I'm in the gym business but we're
babies in content we got like 250
followers on Instagram but we're zero
better than zero what would be some
advice that you had for someone who's
just starting off you need to start
googling and youtubing and educate
yourself on something I call sock
strategic organic content I need you to
understand the thumbnail the first 3
seconds what time you post how many
words which platform what's going on in
LinkedIn carousels that's different than
Facebook carousels Facebook reals What
are broadcast channels my social media
strategy is not the followup
watch this I'm going into my phone I'm
going into my content team WhatsApp
McKenzie on my team said good morning I
need you to post at 5:04 p.m. and 7:07
p.m. on Instagram one needs to be a
carousel one needs to be a real this is
called the science behind the art